[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
five separate bullets a texas police
officer charged in the deadly shooting
of a mentally ill woman
the family of pamela turner speaks out
16 months after her death
i pray that my mother's death would not
be in vain
and legal woes of celebrities from
britney spears to kanye west
analysis you can only see here plus she
was convicted of murder
then acquitted in an internationally
watched trial
amanda knox with a warning for the
audience of tiger k
i found that it was irresponsible for
anyone to be going around claiming that
someone killed their husband
because they happened to see a
documentary series and her advocacy
for justice reform is next on law and
crime daily
[Music]
and welcome everybody to law and crime
daily i'm erin keller along with brian
buckmeyer and terry austin
a texas police officer is out of jail
after he was indicted for shooting a
woman her family says
was schizophrenic baton police officer
juan de la cruz is accused of killing
pamela turner in her apartment complex's
parking lot
in may 2019. de la cruz was serving two
outstanding warrants on turner a
spokesperson for the police initially
said there was a struggle between the
two when the officer
went to arrest turner turner allegedly
reached for the officer's taser and used
it on him
de la cruz in return fired five times
witness cell phone video captured the
incident here
police at the time said the shooting was
justified turner's daughter
disagrees it's very disrespectful
inoffensive you know
if it was anybody else's mother sister
on
all the comments that are said that he
was doing his job
my mom was not a danger she was not a
threat
she was not doing anything to anybody
she took out her trash and she was
walking home
and he took my mother's life she will
never come back i will never hear her
voice again
this is one step closer to getting
the justice that my mom deserves and
and allowing her to be able to rest
respectfully
as she should because she didn't deserve
to die
not like that texas rangers led the
investigation and turned over their
findings to the district attorney's
office brian buckmeyer explains that
process brian
the da's office gave the case to the
grand jury the grand jury
handed up an indictment 16 months after
the shooting
an attorney for the attorney for an
attorney for the turner family
said there was more evidence to be made
public
mr dele cruz actually is a security
officer at the apartment complex
he knew miss turner he knew
that she suffered from mental illness he
knew
that the warrants that he purportedly
wanted to serve
were low-level warrants that did not
need to be served
especially in the evening and especially
in front of somebody's home
when there's been no prior contact with
that individual
those warrants had been there and there
was no urgency to serve those warrants
especially on an individual who you know
is suffering from
mental health issues so right from the
start
we have to look at what was the real
reason
why officer de la cruz decided to serve
those warrants
and interestingly if you look you will
see
that just earlier hours earlier
there was a service of an eviction order
for miss turner
now isn't that convenient that a
security officer
who's going to be responsible for
evicting miss turner
suddenly decides that it's an
appropriate time to serve lawrence
so he can place her in jail and solve
the eviction problem
the indictment accuses de la cruz of
first degree aggravated
assault attorney benjamin crump says the
family is pleased with that charge
they charged him with aggravated assault
which is graded as a felony too
but if the aggravated assault is
committed by a public servant
in the performance of their duties it is
graded as a
felony warrant and as attorney jacobs
and i discussed them we found it
quite fascinating that is the same
as a murder charge manslaughter
is only charged as a felony two but it's
aggravated assault
when committed by a public servant
and performance of their duties is
graded as a felony one
where he can be sentenced to five years
to life in prison
and so we thought that was important to
articulate that we believe kim mark's
office
and the district attorney's office in
harris county texas got it right
the cruz is due in court on october 28th
so terry
this is a little bit fishy to you this
whole concept of the security guard
serving an eviction and then coming back
and serving warrants as a law
enforcement officer
well you know they are trying to make a
claim they said
and under the american with disabilities
act and you know that act
prohibits discrimination against people
with disabilities but
in different areas like employment or
transportation and frankly i don't see
it here whether he was
working as a police officer and
executing these warrants or whether he
was working as a security guard for the
apartment complex
i really don't see that type of cause of
action in a civil lawsuit and
frankly my first federal court trial was
an ada case and i don't see that here
interesting analysis from you terry with
the background on it now brian
the 16-month indictment process is that
ridiculously long or is that
about right in your opinion it really
depends on who you're indicting if it's
someone without a badge then yes that's
ridiculously long if it's someone with a
badge as we're seeing in other cases
briana taylor for example the
prosecution is really
moving slowly to get towards this i
think the best part about this is you
give the information to the grand jury
and you leave it in their hands
sometimes slow and steady wins the race
that's what prosecutors say
an update to a federal report we first
brought you on lawn crime.com and on the
broadcast yesterday
a legal complaint claims a doctor
associated with a federal detention
center
performed unwanted sterilization
procedures on ice detainees
ice responded by saying the office of
the inspector general will investigate
the case
and that it takes allegations seriously
but then added
this in general anonymous unproven
allegations made without any
fact-checkable specifics should be
treated with the appropriate skepticism
they deserve that statement
from immigration and customs enforcement
and still ahead on law on crime daily
kanye west making legal headlines with a
mistake we can all learn from if we ever
need to talk to a lawyer
and later on amanda knox once accused
then exonerated with a warning
for advocates of police reform stay with
us
as long crime daily continues
[Music]
let's take a quick look now at several
celebrities making legal headlines a
star from the netflix docu-series cheer
has been arrested on charges he played a
role in producing child pornography
federal authorities accused jerry harris
of enticing an underage boy to produce
sexually explicit photos and videos the
charges come just after a lawsuit
accused harris
of exploiting two 14 year olds a judge
says hip hop artist nicki minaj did not
infringe the copyrights held by another
artist in connection with the 2017
song sorry grammy-winning artist tracy
chapman said
she repeatedly refused to allow minaj to
use parts of the music
minaj's attorney argued that artists
need to be free to create new music
based on existing material the judge
agreed
that minaj was legally protected by fair
use
an attorney for britney spears has
revealed in court papers that the singer
has
no interest in performing any longer
father jamie spears is britney's
sole conservator he wants another man
andrew wallett
to be appointed to that role britney
spears opposes wallet's appointment
because she doesn't think she'll be able
to afford him
all because she doesn't care to return
to the stage
kanye west disclosing his secret talks
with his lawyers
on twitter the rapper complaining about
his recording contract with universal
claiming it's like quote modern day
slavery
west ended his rant by vowing to do
everything in his legal power to change
all artists contracts
west settled a different lawsuit with
music publisher emi earlier this year so
terry here's the problem with this kanye
west tweeted out several dozen images of
legal documents clearly marked
confidential legal work product
privilege that is
every attorney's fear yes
it is and you know frankly i'm assuming
that they had a confidentiality
agreement in place
and if they did i'm sure they're
liquidated damages and
the attorneys can actually go after him
for that but you know what is even
more disturbing is the fact that he put
this in
the public and it's now in the public
domain so
any proprietary work product that the
lawyers had
are you know that's now gone it's not a
secret if you disclose it brian i was
always taught in law school ethics class
look you need to warn your clients
that this is supposed to be just between
us and if you disclose it
the jig is up the secret's out exactly
attorney-client privilege is
powerful it can't be pierced by
virtually anything
but once one side often times in this
case the client starts speaking that
gets absolutely destroyed
and you best believe that his attorneys
are really frustrated and
probably are really hoping that kanye
takes care of himself and hoping the
other side isn't looking at all those
documents right now because that opens
another can of worms anyway coming up
next
amanda knox once convicted then
exonerated in a high-profile
international
murder shares her thoughts about carol
baskin tiger king
and what she thinks is wrong with the
police that's right after this
[Music]
and out of my conversation with amanda
knox about justice in america high
profile cases making headlines black
lives matter
the police and her own exoneration in
the killing of her overseas roommate
since then she has authored a book and
has begun hosting a podcast and facebook
show called
the truth about true crime she's
advocating for
a renewed focus on fairness for
defendants while acknowledging advocates
on all sides of hot button issues
could benefit from a time out for
self-reflection
amanda you as an american were
exonerated of a murder in italy are
there parallels to your case in the
american justice system
oh my gosh um so many i i it's hard to
count how many um i think that the
criminal justice system
throughout the world and particularly
here in the united states
is often thwarted by a number of
different
issues within the criminal justice
system i mean what we're looking at
is a system where prosecutors law
enforcement police investigators
are not incentivized to find the truth
they're incentivized to win
they're incentivized to find answers and
and you know tie a neat little bow on
societal problems
and that means that there is inevitably
going to be people who can't afford
the kind of justice that they deserve
and the kind of defense that they
deserve
um becoming victims of the criminal
justice system here and abroad when you
talk about affording that sort of
defense they deserve are you talking
about lawyers fees we have public
defenders of course
or is it getting into forensics and
other things that cost a lot more money
absolutely i mean it comes to all of
those things right so
public defenders we know are not given
the resources and funding they need to
actually
provide the service that their clients
deserve
um especially considering the kind of
resources that we make available to
prosecutors
um beyond that what is necessary
to these days to prove one's innocence
is
forensic testing is you know we need all
of these very expensive resources that
most people do
not have available to them it's a common
problem that if you can afford someone
to do
the proper investigation you have a
chance of justice in our criminal
justice system
and the key word i think there was
proper investigation because courts have
to
authorize some degree of investigation
states set aside money for defendants
who don't have the money to pay
otherwise to actually
pay for those services up front the
question is are they sufficient
right and also are the state entities
being incentivized to pursue
all of the available leads that are
available to them
are they following where the evidence is
leading them or are they pursuing only
evidence to confirm a theory
that they can then present to a court
when long-time daily returns amanda
knocks on the hit true crime series
tiger king and her stern warning for the
audience
the conversation continues in just a
moment
another moment from my conversation with
murder exoneree amanda knox who has
turned her attention toward advocacy for
defendants finding themselves in the
same situation
she was once in knox identifies with
protesters against overzealous
prosecutors and police brutality but
believes it's unfair to characterize
police officers
as a whole as evil
the black lives matter movement and
protests across the country have changed
the conversation about the role of the
police
what's your assessment of the alleged
acts of the police and the response from
the communities as you look at these
protests big picture
it's so so important that these
conversations
are finally finally happening it's a
shame that it's taken this long
and i share the protesters sense of
urgency that these
issues need to be addressed now we need
to address the root causes
of crimes and we need to remember to be
cautious against any kind of us versus
them mentality
us versus them mentality is the root of
police brutality
because the police have otherized whole
communities
that they don't view as people that they
are
there to protect but to protect against
and we should resist any kind of
language that also
otherwise is police officers that is not
taking into account their humanization
as well
we need to look at the incentives and
root causes of all these social
dysfunctions and address them directly
nox's opinions on current social issues
are influenced of course by her own case
she talked about what she says went
wrong in italy a decade ago
and about a few other high-profile
people claiming
their own innocence these days the
police
are not doing things because of
malicious intent
i don't think that that's what's
happening i think what the police are
doing
is they're following the path of least
resistance and they're finding the
person who is most vulnerable
to manipulation basically
so they found me they saw me in a
vulnerable state they saw that i had
no one there to to protect me to stand
by me
my parents weren't there i was alone
and i was pushed to the point where i
broke basically i told the police again
and again and again
everything that i knew they didn't
accept that i didn't know anything more
than what i was saying
and they pushed me to the point where i
began to believe
what they told me which was that i had
amnesia and didn't remember
all of the things that i knew about the
crime
it seems like a far-fetched theory by
the police
oh certainly well i mean i i think that
when
i was going through my interrogation the
police didn't
know what happened okay they thought
that i knew what happened and they
thought
that there was some kind of sex game
that went awry
because there had been evidence that my
roommate had been assaulted sexually
and that somehow i might know who might
have done it that i might have been
involved
and if i a young woman with no criminal
record
were involved then it must be some kind
of
horrendous sex game that's the theory
and it all derived from trying to force
me into
a sexual assault murder equation
that i certainly did not fit into
prosecutors and law enforcement are
incentivized to win at all costs
to not admit fault and in order to do so
they basically railroad innocent people
speaking of innocence a lot of
high-profile people in true crime series
are professing theirs
so big question should joe exotic from
tiger king
be pardoned be pardoned
um let's see i mean so i don't want to
make any strong claims about any case
that i have not personally looked into
um i have not personally looked into the
joe exotic
case i saw a documentary like many of us
saw and my simple reaction to that case
was actually in response to carol baskin
and
the number of people who saw a
documentary and made a claim
about how carol baskin killed her
husband and
i found that it was irresponsible for
anyone to be going around
claiming that someone killed their
husband because they happen to see a
documentary series that's not enough
to actually make any kinds of claims of
guilt or innocence
as for carol paskins specifically when
she says she had nothing to do with her
husband's disappearance do you believe
her
i think that there is enough
circumstantial evidence to pursue
an investigation but as far as what was
presented to
within the documentary i can't say
either way if i believe her or not
all journalists and all prosecutors and
you know are all going to be coming
presenting evidence to you from a
certain perspective
and their their ins their perspective is
informed by the information and the
research that they've done
but that doesn't mean that their
perspective should necessarily be yours
it's important to hear the other side to
weigh the evidence and to give it if you
want to make a claim
or an assertion any kind of conviction
needs to have
been the amount of context and homework
done that most people don't want to do
frankly your work generally encourages
people to reflect on criminal cases by
looking beyond headlines to not rush to
judgment
it sounds like that's basically what
you're suggesting here
absolutely i mean
these are real people's lives and it's
easy to forget that when we see
someone's
face on the front page and their name in
a headline
these are human beings just like you and
me and they deserve
no matter what they've done every
benefit of the doubt
and every protection that our state has
to offer amanda knox thanks for the
conversation
thank you
broadcast now so terry we covered a lot
of ground there amanda knox and i
i was struck by a reminder that as
jurors if we're called to jury duty we
need to remember the state has the
burden and we need to
hold the state to the burden absolutely
that was an excellent interview aaron i
think wise words from a wise woman
making sure that people out there don't
really jump to conclusions and to your
point if you are selected as a juror
you shouldn't have your mind made up and
since she's been through that type of
process
she knows well how it goes so wise words
she certainly has spent a lot of time
thinking about things that we talk about
around this desk and elsewhere on law
and crime daily
brian her comments about public
defenders we need better discovery rules
to make it easier for people like you to
do your job
exactly it's a complicated issue i would
not put it all to the feet of public
defenders
are there public defenders who don't do
their job correctly yes like any other
profession
but many of us are shackled by poor
discovery laws
information that's not giving to us lack
of resources investigators social
workers
it takes a lot to represent an
individual and unless the state is going
to give that
there's going to be very very many
people found guilty when they're
actually innocent
brian and terry so glad to be along with
you both today thank you for joining us
on law and crime daily we'll see you
next time for our discussions about
justice in america
if you can't wait for more court cam new
episodes
are on their way this october get ready
to take a front row seat
again because you won't have to wait
long for more
court cam new season coming this october
on a
e i'm dan abrams
and this is the law on crime network the
only 24 7 network with
expert legal analysis and gavel to gavel
live trial coverage watch the law on
crime network
[Music]
today
[Music]
[Applause]
you